okay I'd like to just start by thanking
the organizers for the invitation to be
here to speak to you all I'm going to
talk about the health impacts of methyl
mercury in fish and marine mammals and
when I say methyl mercury I want to I
want you to think about methyl mercury
as a prototype for bioaccumulative
contaminants so methyl mercury like many
persistent synthetic organic chemicals
that we release bio magnifies and
aquatic food webs and what I mean by
that is because shows so for each
successive trophic level in a food web
so as each organism eats other organisms
you have a magnification of that
chemical in a food web so in aquatic
environments concentrations can be very
low in the aqueous environment so in the
water or seawater and you can get
concentrations then and top predators
that are a million times are more higher
and so what that means about your food
source is then that that dietary intake
becomes a concentrated source of
chemical exposure now fish and marine
mammals so I work in a number of
northern Arctic populations those are
essential food sources for many of these
people so this becomes a large intake
source for these toxic chemicals now
methyl mercury specifically has been
associated with a variety of adverse
health effects the developing fetus is
the most sensitive target for methyl
mercury particularly during the third
trimester of pregnancy and this has been
associated with long-term neurocognitive
delays in children you know I could go
on about health impacts of methyl
mercury or all or any of these other
chemicals I think we can all agree we
would like less of them in our food it
becomes much more complicated when we
start looking at the food itself so when
you start to think about seafood or
marine mammals in these populations
that's their traditional diet if you
advise people to change their
traditional diet
or to eat less fish then you're
introducing a whole nother risk scenario
because moving away so these the fish in
the marine mammals contain essential
micronutrients like long-chain omega-3
fatty acids which is what I'm showing
you here on the y-axis and as an example
you're seeing methyl mercury on the
x-axis okay and these are a variety of
commonly consumed fish species so you
don't want to advise people to consume
less seafood because in our population
for example we have a deficiency in
long-chain omega-3 fatty acids in
general but so how do you craft advice
then for consumers and this has been the
focus of the public health discussion
around methyl mercury and many of these
bio accumulative contaminants you know
how do you craft a risk message that
isn't actually harmful to public health
you can see from this plot that you it
is actually possible to pick species
that are relatively high in omega-3
fatty acids for example and low in
methyl mercury or species that are high
in methyl mercury but low in
micronutrients so you can craft a
message it's very complicated
so you think about introducing public
health messages it's very difficult to
parse a message for the general public
as complicated as this one my colleagues
and I so this was led by Emily Oken in
the in the medical school wrote a review
paper on this in Environmental Health
Perspectives
if you're interested in this topic about
sort of the the various dimensions that
go into thinking about individual
choices related to seafood consumption
so bioaccumulative contaminants the
nutritional elements of seafood the
sustainability of those fish stocks
themselves and then the economic
implications so are these different
choices affordable and that's very
interesting it's been you know it's it's
a complicated scenario because we're
talking about you know intervening in
people's you know what kind of dietary
interventions could we make those
arguments are largely centered on the
North American population or the the
develops are developing or developed
countries populations
and what I'd like to introduce now is
just getting us thinking more broadly
about what perhaps are some other
implications for public health of
bioaccumulative contaminants in marine
fisheries so when you look at so I
always I always start with okay well so
we want to ground this because fish and
marine mammals are one of our last wild
food sources they come from the
environment where do they actually come
from and we're thinking about changes in
those contaminant burdens you have to be
thinking about changes in the quality of
those physical ecosystems themselves so
you know the statistical data behind
this is something that I've been looking
at for a number of years so for methyl
mercury as an example in the United
States we get so this is fisheries
biomass that's being shown to you on on
the in terms of the percentages on this
slide if we think about the fraction of
methyl mercury intake in the US
population more than half of that is
coming from the Pacific Ocean
specifically the westerns but the
western Pacific Ocean because of the
seafood species that concentrate methyl
mercury and where they're harvested so
you know we think about global
contaminants or bioaccumulative global
contaminant contaminants as distributed
through the atmosphere sometimes we
think about them is distributed through
global ocean circulation and we also
redistribute them through the global
commercial fisheries market okay so this
is why we perhaps have been concerned
from a public health perspective about
releases in these different regions
another dimension to this public health
problem is the communities that rely on
these resources exclusively so we have
choices we have lots of food
alternatives that can affect our health
when you think about some of these
coastal communities in East Asia that
rely on these resources they have very
few choices okay so it's an essential
source of micronutrients it's an
essential source of protein in the
Arctic if you tell somebody to switch
away from their country foods then
they're immediately shifting to
store-bought food which is just starch
and sugar okay so it's a it's a very
large Public Health
problem if we look at so this is you
know transitioning into what my group
has focused on over the past several
years again for mercury so we're looking
at where do those contaminants go when
they're released into the physical
environment and what we find so this is
building on recently we did a global
inventory from Mercury in rivers and we
put that into an ocean general
circulation model to look at where does
that Glo go globally and how does it
disperse and what you see on the far
side here is the Arctic and this is
zooming in on a region of on the Asian
coastline and what you see obviously is
that there's a concentration of mercury
in these coastal areas and so the
implication again when you look at the
the concentrations in these fish they're
already starting to exceed toxicological
thresholds where we see effects so this
has been virtually unconsidered or not
considered in the management of these
fish stocks themselves but the larger
public health I just want to leave you
with this the larger public health
concern that I think we should be
thinking about is what happens if you
know these large concentrations from
industrialization in Asia largely in the
Arctic a lot of these processes are
being forced by climate variability so
for permafrost melt freshwater discharge
patterns you're threatened you're going
to start to threaten the stocks
themselves and so this is what we're
looking into now thank you sorry